Baltimore is considering a curfew for
teenagers that's right in a preliminary
vote the City Council
approved a bill that could make
baltimore's curfew laws among the
strictest in the country
I basically this it started because a
bunch of teens rampaging through a 7-11
last year lotta vandalizing and stuff
like that we've got some details on the
curfew
kids under the age of 14 would need to
be home by 9pm year-round
kids age 14 to 16 would have a curfew at
10 p.m. on weeknights during the school
year
and 11 p.m. on weekends there would also
be a daytime curfew during school hours
and more than one citation could result
in a hefty fine
I don't like this I don't like this
I don't think we need the nanny state
that lead then to the police state which
then leads to the militarized state
i watch our site fiction yeah I'm is
merely that we've seen this movie before
yeah I just take it well nothing I i
agree with you I'm I'd
I think this is way overkill because
it's
taking and something that didn't happen
a real incident that did frighten people
you know there was a growing up
teenagers running around in
you know I don't know exactly how much
you know havoc they reply or
teenagers do when we dance videos
popping up and say those in 7 11
right some reason teenagers that go in
there that snap up all the slim
but you know a curfew isn't necessarily
going to make any difference on that you
have to have a police officer or other
official there to actually catch them in
the active not meeting their curfew
and give them a ticket at the time so
all you have to do is just not but the
cops catch you and then boom curfew is
useless
but also seems to me to be overly
restrictive
you know you've got kids you have to
work after school you have kids to
I have to get to have late night
reversals and beer for example you know
you have to
I think it's too restrictive and it
basically punishes all kids for just a
few kids who are
I'm unable to find something to do with
himself right 9 p.m.
should kids be in bed at night I mean
basic yet to be home playing video games
like you can either be outta part right
chasing a ball perhaps yeah I'm doing an
IBM
ok I've gone out last night yeah for
today
yeah I yeah I like the other kids are
the ones who are definitely
going out how rather you know it sweeps
in a lot of kids that wouldn't
necessarily be the ones that are being
the one search both bracketed by to
yet my biggest issue I totally agree is
that this is conditioning these kids at
a very young age to
to know that if they or their peers you
the battle and about line then the
government comes in and says you guys
cannot be trusted
with freedom you have to be contained in
restraining your homes and I think that
really sends a bad message to somebody
who just ordered grows up and and and
gets bad idea at a young age that
they're going to be
taken control yeah I I totally agree
that's why the part
about the school day that the kurds you
wouldn't be
the you know warranty during the school
day is even worse to me that the night
time thing because playing hooky is like
part of growing
aa you really mean there's a great
episode where The Simpsons where part
doesn't go to school the whole episode
is Principal Skinner chasing him around
town like that apart
grow up in fighting the system and not
being conditioned to always believe in
power to do that
part seem worse maybe than the nighttime
part to me
hey it's cool I know where is the
location yeah
ever happened and why I am now I that's
an iconic film set up
I don't wanna the other part about it is
that you know they're going to find the
parents and I think that
if you are a parent and you are say
working two jobs and you're not able to
be home in the evenings and so you know
obviously sometimes teenagers are gonna
go do impulsive things like run around
when they don't have somebody
so it seems better to not punish the
parents who may not have the resources
to ensure that they're teenagers are
occupied and something
constructive you may be the city could
turn that money instead
over two programs in places for kids to
go rights or punishing the people who
are ready
are behind it but yeah you know we would
I wouldn't generally guess that you know
parents who have to be at work at night
are would not appreciate
you know having to be fine for something
because they don't have the resources to
give their kids something to do
you know there are policies that show
that if you provide you know basketball
court in a recreation centers in a place
for kids to go teens to go there safe
don't go there yeah I remember growing
up in my guy would always be trying to
get me and the basement play video games
with my friends and I only you're the
there was a lip basketball court at
night we would have been running around
but there were no lid
best word kids want to be outside I
think general yeah
and i think is a as a big I don't know
what pre thomas edison
world you go whether or not I basketball
courts and I guess that maybe that
I grew by the roadside attraction and I
i don't know
right but the other side they had the
lib at why I think the crazy thing is
especially summer is coming up July 4th
2012 gonna have to leave before the
fireworks started I am i mean it just
seems
absurdly overreaching but I the regular
I guess they they could probably be out
with their parents I'm sure there's
partner but I mean I reckon it when I
right thing I wasn't going out to eat
with my parents to go watch fireworks
side on I think the real problem
obviously is the kids are acting out
this is just this is not addressing the
real issue here right what we should do
have empower adults would be believed
beat the shit outta the skin yeah I line
and then because if there's consequences
related to the active
be acting out you know into the police
are there going to be like well I had
i'd give a weapon because
whose troops and their 711 I am I didn't
get out or going to the crew into the
Pro
beating paid realm with all that
controversy you to come into effect
yeah %uh to so playing the devil's
advocate a little bit so I'll give you
the child beating thing
is it may be only some love this may be
OK at the most
local level that if they're is it how
that something was really I i
personally don't like them yes level
that yeah just really at the really
micro level if there was a little town
somewhere where just all hell was
breaking loose
that the local a car yes and by the way
yeah that's probably an extreme case
like you say
like maybe see that happening and they
don't downplay
were around down what you know about an
idea I don't let
apocalypse you definitely need occur
yeah you know but now I don't literally
I don't really see why they want I'm
actually I take that back
I do see why they would prefer to put in
it a curfew because it actually requires
very little
from the city as far as resource agent
it just means that the cops get to go
find
kids to take it and then it's a little
bit more stores a revenue for the city
because they get the fine parents but
you know I can see them not wanting to
put the effort
into actually dealing with the problem
in creating a solution to the problem
rather than just
you know putting a band-aid on it Wow a
solution to a problem rather than
conditioning kids to think that they're
criminals and
record